the taliban was forced out in 2001.
in 2021 they're back
fighters taking jalalabad with little to
no resistance
in the space of a week they've seized
control of the entire country
and as afghans prepare for the militia
to rule them once again
who are the taliban and what do we
expect now
last month sky news was invited to meet
them sky's special correspondent alex
crawford the first foreign journalist to
be shown their military strength
can anyone believe that the taliban
wants peace when you've you've got all
these weapons now
the taliban now appeared to be more
powerful more sophisticated and richer
than ever before
but those who lived in afghanistan under
the brutal taliban rule of 20 years ago
are fearful of a return to the past what
the taliban have been doing in areas
under their control it
totally points to the opposite they have
closed down schools for women they have
when when
government female employees have
tried to go to the office they've
essentially told them that you cannot
enter you should go back home and stay
at home
in the taliban controlled areas
witnessed by sky news there were no
women seen out in public as they took
control in the country's capital kabul's
streets emptied
under its oppressive rule in the 1990s
women and girls were denied education
and weren't allowed outdoors without a
male chaperone
despite the taliban now promising to
protect women's rights
many were seen hurrying home
there's a very real worry what this
takeover means for the future of afghan
women and children
my family left afghanistan in 1999
fleeing taliban ruled just two years
after 9 11. so i was a very a young
child when uh when we fled i i thought
that this was this chapter was over and
that i'd never have to relive it again
for two decades the taliban have fought
against coalition forces and the
internationally recognized afghan
government
the country had become a training ground
for terrorists many now fear terrorism
will once again breed within its borders
they've been given reassurances to all
the neighbors
and all interested parties that they
will not allow anybody to use their soil
to launch attacks on any other nation
um so i hope
and i think
i'm amongst millions that will hold the
same that that will never happen
after 20 years of conflict that has cost
the afghan people dearly
the president has now left the country
and the taliban are back in control
this time
attempting to appear more acceptable to
the world
sally lockwood sky news